make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so I know I said in the last video that
Marvel doesn't really take the easy way
out when it comes to these stories they
definitely do in this part
they definitely go full cheapskate when
it gets to this part so this initially
picks up with with issue number four I
think it is oh when it's the hunt for
Hope Summers so what this means is of
course Hope Summers those guys who read
Avengers vs. x-men was supposed to be
the new Messiah for the various mutant
population that was out there or at
least a new house for the Phoenix force
the idea behind hope is that she's
ridiculously powerful right hope had the
ability to copy the powers of anybody
and the indication was that there was no
upper limit right so she could copy
anybody's powers and then use them in
the most extreme form and that's kind of
the funny thing that's kind of a funny
thing about her character is just how
crazy powerful she is right so in a lot
of ways she was kind of underrated cuz
mama didn't really do a whole lot with
her outside of generation Hope and the
12 lights after that it was just kind of
like okay she's a character who's there
she pops back up again in Avengers vs.
x-men and then that's basically it but
she's ridiculously opy she's one of
those like well beyond Omega level
characters but with this fight this this
particular instance this is Captain
America vs gambit right so in the
attempt by Captain America to basically
locate Hope Summers he ends up stumbling
across the path of gambit now my initial
inclination here and my initial thought
was this is a terrible mismatch right
Captain America vs gambit what a
terrible mismatch between characters
Captain America vs beast would be a more
reasonable approach given the enhanced
strength of beast and his agility which
would certainly make fighting him by
Captain America a pretty difficult task
right it'd be pretty tough for him to
overtake beast but then like literally
Steve McNiven starts writing the story
and I'm just like okay so this is
amazing so it's one of the coolest
things right like gambit jumps out of
nowhere
throw some kinetic recharge playing
cards and we're off to the races right
Captain America immediately rebounds
throws his shield and it's one of the
coolest things right because gambit
dodges out of the way like and then he
grabs the shield but he grabs his shield
dodges out of the way and it's one of
the coolest moments ever
he kinetically charges the shield and
he's like I suppose you want this back
and throws it back at Captain America
and like this is one of the coolest
things I've ever seen to be honest with
you guys I feel like we may have covered
this portion during the Avengers vs.
x-men story that we did I don't know I
don't care it's awesome it's worth
covering again like it's it's amazing
right like literally Captain America
throwing a shield as gambit gambit
catching it charging it and throwing it
back it's one of the most awesome things
it's one of the most awesome moments
right because like from there
Captain America dodges out of the way
now here's the important thing to
understand here in this fight between
these two guys Captain America is doing
double duty right like he's trying to
talk Tony Stark and try and listen when
everybody else is saying and then at the
same time fighting gambit so in reality
gambit doesn't even have the full
attention of Captain America right now
this is one of the important things to
also understand here that gambit is a
good fighter right gambit is a really
really good fighter but Captain America
is a prodigious fighter he's probably in
the top three best fighters in Marvel
Comics the only person that I would say
is better than Captain America and holy
a few of the characters is Tony masters
right taskmaster taskmaster is the best
fighter in all of Marvel Comics that guy
is legit
Tony masters the coolest thing about him
he consumed a formula and so basically
the way this works is that whenever he
watches somebody fight he basically
fights like them right so if he fights
Captain America he'll basically start to
mirror Captain America's fighting style
not only that like it's literally just
pulling out cards right so all the
yesterday was think of daredevil and
then he starts fighting like daredevil
he has to think of like Elektra then he
starts fighting like a lecture it works
that way right if if Tony masters ever
met Batman then he would just have to
start thinking like thinking about
Batman and he'd be able to fight like
Batman right it's crazy how capable he
is that's why is why he's just such a
ridiculously good fighter the Captain
America getting the upper hand on gambit
is more than believable but this is why
gambit is so cool right this is why
gambit is so interesting the thing about
gambit is this right gambit one of these
characters where he's always outnumbered
but never outgunned and it's this cool
thing right because he immediately
touches Captain America's hand and the
response of Captain America is look man
you know you're you're at a touch dude
like like you are really at a touch
right you cannot charge organic matter
there's no point in trying to charge me
and the response at gambit is yeah man
but like those scales weren't made by
fish and like charges the armor of
Captain America and sends him flying
like blows his armor up like blows up as
his suit missile Captain America is just
sitting there all tattered and
everything you know yeah but initially
gets kind of arrogant right he's like
one guy down like living legend down for
the count and there's a little bit of
you know kind of like you know
cheeriness going on there you know from
gambit and then Captain America gets up
and he's like Captain America is like
that's cute man now you have my
undivided attention and you're gonna
wish you hadn't this is why I say this
is better than pretty much all the other
fights right because the fall of gambit
happens with a quickness right it goes
just like this gambit charges cars and
throws on Captain America blocks it with
the shield charges a gambit gambit goes
to kick his kid gets blocked with a
shield Captain America punches
gambits down done like it's just like
[Laughter]
yes it's like damn it's it's cool like
it's really cool right it's really
awesome to see but like gambits
basically down for the count right
Captain America is like okay new plan
we don't have to chase hope anymore
we're BC and this of course continues on
with the rest of the Avengers vs. x-men
comic but like it's legit man like it's
one of the coolest things from here we
jump to unstoppable Colossus vs
spider-man now here's the thing right
here's the thing that Spider Man but
spider-man has faced off and and managed
to get the upper hand on a lot of heroes
multiple times over the years now a lot
of people out there who are really
hardline about whether or not somebody's
defeated is like do you knock them out
or something like that but spider-man
has gotten the upper hand on heroes
multiple times right we saw that during
Secret Wars when he basically got the
upper hand on all of the x-men right and
ended up taking Charles Xavier with this
telepathy to get the upper hand on
spider-man right the spider-man haters
were just like he didn't defeat anybody
but it was like no man he kind of did
right like if you don't believe that
you're just delusional and there's no
there's no arguing that point but like
it's it was crazy because him facing off
against unstoppable Colossus the reality
of this is this is a fight he should
never win I cannot envision a feasible
circumstance whereby spider-man can get
the upper hand on unstoppable Colossus
right because you're talking about
Colossus so who also possesses the power
of the juggernaut right so not only is
it Colossus with his osmium metal skin
now he's also amped up in terms of
physical strength he doesn't need to
sleep he doesn't need to eat he doesn't
need to breathe or anything like that
he's just like this immutable force of
destruction seemingly like it's the most
overpowered version of Colossus that
we've ever seen in the history of Marvel
Comics it's kind of insane but the funny
thing about this if spider-man is always
ready for a conflict like this first
thing he does blind the guy you can't
hit what you can't see and that's the
coolest thing right like blind this guy
frustrated him and that's the benefit of
spider-man that for a long time in
spider-man's comics he would always tell
jokes he would never really seem to take
the fight seriously and there was a
really really good moment in Dan Slott
spider-man renew your vows where he
explains why right in spider-man it's
like I do that because if I'm cracking
jokes the villains don't think I'm
taking them seriously and
think I'm not taking them seriously then
they start to get irritated and they
start to get angry they go off kilter
and they stop they stop focusing and
fighting in an efficient manner and it
makes it easier to defeat them but
blinding Colossus right off the bat is
the smartest move from there he webs his
feet up and slows his movement now keep
in mind he's cracking jokes and messing
around and all that kind of stuff the
entire time but Colossus immediately
gets the webbing out of his eyes
collapses hand gives one of those great
big huge you know Hulk claps and then
knocks spider-man off-kilter and it's
kind of crazy because from there it's
just throwing spider-man around like a
rag doll and it's one of these things
where Peters just constantly on the
defensive and that's really kind of the
nature of Peter Parker as the nature of
spider-man when it comes to fighting a
foe that's so superior to himself is
this using a combination of his spider
sense and dodging now under any normal
circumstance this would work right like
you would just have to wait them out
it's the rope-a-dope technique from the
old uh from the old Muhammad Ali fight
right those guys who know about that
Muhammad Ali fought George Foreman
George Foreman was was just big and
bulky right he was a great big huge
bulky guy and if he got his hands on
Muhammad Ali he would have worn him out
so the response of Muhammad Ali was let
him wear himself out right so just let
him pummel o Muhammad Ali right just
just block just put up sharks slit and
beat on being on the guy like a rag doll
let him tire himself out and then go in
for the kill that's usually what
Spiderman does right especially when it
comes to like a bigger a bigger force
than himself but remember this is
unstoppable Colossus his energy will go
on forever he doesn't tire so that that
kind of strategy will not work here and
so basically it's an unstoppable force
meets a movable object and so he should
be defeated right like a movable object
not immovable but a movable object like
he should be defeated real quick fast
and in a hurry that's how that should go
down and so at this point it's just
spider-man blocking shots just just
dodging and trying to stay out of harm's
way here's a problem with this fight
here's the issue with this it just ends
literally daredevil comes out of nowhere
and he's like Hope Summers is in a year
and so spider-man's like okay well let's
go and he just swings away with
daredevil and the fight just ends we
don't actually get a winner here like we
don't actually find out who wins in this
fight right between these two but here's
what I want to know how about you guys
to answer this for me my votes
unstoppable Colossus and not even by a
little bit like by a lot right like my
vote is unstoppable Colossus would
absolutely demolish Peter Parker but I'm
curious what you guys think right
because Peters also one of the smartest
people
the world and while colossus is not an
idiot he had the sharpest tool in the
shed right i mean it's one of these
things where the engines running and
sometimes there's nobody behind the
wheel right you know so that's kind of
how is how is his character works you
know it's one of these things where
peter's much smarter Peter Kali would
have found a way around him but I don't
know I want to know what your all's take
is who do you guys think would have won
between this fight between spider-man in
the unstoppable Colossus but that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]